also insane over the last 24 hours there
is a new Rolling Stone report Trump
asking advisors for battle plans to
attack Mexico if re-elected this is
truly horrifying he probably watched an
episode of narcos Mexico and was like I
should get some plans to invade the
article reads Trump and his magnified
Republican party are pushing plans for
military action against drug cartels in
Mexico with or without the Mexican
government's consent
Trump is asking for a plan to wage war
in Mexico
and the Republican party is eager to
give it to him Trump has been asking
policy advisors for Military options to
take on Mexican drug cartels including
doing strikes not sanctioned by Mexico's
government according to two sources
familiar with the situation attacking
Mexico or whatever you'd like to call it
is something that President Trump has
said he wants battle plans drawn for
says a source he's complained about
missed opportunities of his first term
and there are a lot of people around him
who want fewer missed opportunities in a
second term listen to this Trump
lieutenants imagine having lieutenants
Trump lieutenants have briefed him on
several options that include unilateral
military strikes and Troop deployments
on a sovereign U.S partner and neighbor
can you imagine the United States
unilaterally deploying troops in Mexico
this is exact you know when we talk
about
Trump wanting to Nuke a hurricane Trump
not understanding why considering using
nukes on Europe is insane this is the
sort of stuff we're talking about this
is the really dangerous stuff
um one such proposal that Trump has been
briefed on is a white paper from the
center for renewing America which is
increasingly influential and it's
staffed by Trump wonks and magaloyalists
and it's called it's time to wage war on
transnational drug cartels this is all
so insane so insane what they should do
is come to Trump you know these big
strong guys they should go to Trump With
Tears in their eyes and say sir
the wall you built it's so powerful that
we can no longer invade Mexico the wall
is too tall for us to invade and attack
Mexico we can't do it this is an example
of the dangerous nature of another Trump
presidency because he will be even more
unhinged the Counterpoint is
Trump's not really going to do this but
Ron DeSantis if he were the president
might actually do some really dangerous
stuff I can see it both ways I really
can but these are horrifyingly dangerous
ideas